j'ai une surprise du wif ben oui je vous
le dis 18 janvier 2002 voyez de quoi je
parle nous la carte paris qui me dit
quelque chose s'est passé je revenais se
contente de noir on va voir le magnéto
je vous en parle juste
[Musique]
jean-michel si vous étiez célibataire je
le suis si on devait faire le portrait
robot de la femme idéale c'est le
portrait craché l'oeil belges adorent le
charme oriental que bouche pulpeuse de
l'effort la trouve super bass entre jean
michel tu vas voir des verts avec nous
tu ailles mêmes antennes des pizzas
évidemment je vais le pechoux ont eu
trop d'accords quelques jeux boit ses
paroles pointent dans sa gueule de son
état il est derrière est ce que jean
michel maire aurait peu votre style de
près ou de loin
je comprends la délivre sa 4ème s'est
fait une réputation qui le précède
sabrina fou de vous c'est jean michel
maire il est tombé amoureux
voilà je suis ici sabrina s'est vendu ça
conclut non non ça c'est avec sophie
davant
jean-michel sophie davant la rencontre
de tous univers qui ne demandent qu'une
chose aller sophie davant
des rêves ton corps encore
partout
[Musique]
quand je t'aime
pour toujours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà jamie cher mais bon ça fait donc
onze ans que vous êtes avec moi on est
dans un vol dakar direction paris classe
économique des états sur milieu de
l'appareil
c'est un vol de nuit l'hôtesse de l'air
baisse les volets des hublots et
pourrait changer vous échangé un regard
et votre voisine de gauche la turbulence
à signaler merci jean pascal de revenir
merci merci jours parce que sa maman
chérie ray ça s'est arrangé chérie tu as
beaucoup de chance parce qu'elles sont
il est propre il est boudée badischer
avis alors tu vas pas parce que l'on
parle d'amour aux sélections michel mais
j'ai entendu jean michel il n'y a pas eu
de turbulences à signaler à part dans
votre pantalon si vous payez j'aimerais
vraiment qu'on fasse le s'il vous plaît
les chéris je voudrais vraiment qu'on
fasse ce silence sur le plateau les
chéris parce qu'on n'entend rien et
qu'on coupe le micro de huy clap qui
donne des instructions sushis que les
chéris s'il vous plaît merci
voilà merci en régie est-ce qu'on est en
direct jean michel maire est ce que vous
vous rappelez de sevrey à boeing très
bon ça arrive patron de six mille fois
dans sa vie qu'est ce qui s'est passé
j'ai eu une sorte de coup de foudre dont
sur le vol dakar par contre ont dû
parler dakar c'est danny williams johnny
vient donc je sais pas quelle année
c'est aimé vous en avez parlé même dans
votre livre
ouais alors sauf qu'on ne signale ya un
détail important c'est que vous avez
oublié au petit matin alors qu'elle
buvait un jus de tomate
je l'avais oublié la renaissance mais
voulait dire non elle vous a laissé un
souvenir au goût amer
elle vous a jeté un verre au visage avec
une petite insulte aux jean-michel on va
faire le test ensemble nous avons
retrouvé trois femmes qui correspondent
au profil qui est avec vous sur ce
fameux vol en 18 sont les solutions il
ya 18 ans oui à toi aussi
ce n'est pas la première s'appelle vous
allez voir je ne peux pas vous dire
comment il s'appelle la première la
première la deuxième le problème et
trois jeunes filles qui vont arriver
on va les faire venir l'une après
l'autre pour recréer la situation de cet
avion vous allez devoir essayer de
retrouver
laquelle est la fameuse inconnu du vol
747 points
les trois filles donc vaut boire un jus
de tomate et vous refaire la scène comme
ça s'est passé au petit matin puisque
c'est une vraie histoire vraiment s'il
vous plaît venez et on va appuyer
la prétendante par minute de ces trois y
avait cette jeune fille avec qui vous
avez une relation lors de ce vol sur ce
747 bon j'essaie de trouver laquelle
bonsoir merci aux essais trouver
laquelle merci d'être avec nous merci
est magnifique
alors mettez vous là bas jean michel
allé l'argent je vais d'abord à venir
sur jean-michel distances de sécurité
bien sûr dans la mi-temps va refaire la
scène de fin elle est belle il faut
cesser de l'attrait aussi celle où
porsche voulait nous agace trois ans
vous direz laquelle était avec vous dans
ce championnat où je peux lui poser des
questions non non non elle va t-il se
refaire la scène la lexus a croqué la
scène de fin ou elbaz a jeté le vert à
la gueule c'est la chaîne allait trouver
d'autres il ajouté approchez-vous avec
le che mettez-vous de chaque côté du
pupitre
merci parce qu'ils avaient une façon
particulièrement oui je me bats me
superbement là ça se passe mal à la fin
au petit matin c'est pas que ça se passe
on ne sait pas comment c'est pas à moi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé refaites nous
la scène je fais une grosse mais je
reconnais pas la voix merci merci
attention donc il ya bien longtemps que
j'ai pas retrouvé a parmi ces trois
femmes celles qui étaient bien là avec
vous sur le gold rumeurs sur ce boeing
merci asseyez vous est simple un double
et bravo la deuxième un bravo
classe
[Musique]
la deuxième est splendide au ciel
s'appelle cathy merci d'être là kattié
merci à tous bienvenue cats et canal
jean katie white organes ne regardent
déjà quatre places en jeu soit qu'elle a
vécu là c'est ma copine sannois ati ont
remonté la seine sur ce prix ça
éclabousse aussi une proche on n'est pas
loin quant à lui j'ai pas dis là
n'étaient que je veux dire un truc n'a
pas collé les c'est une histoire de
cheryl assez attention troisième
ah oui bah oui 3 attention bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être là magnifique aussi
alors allez-y
donc est ce que c'est vous qui était sur
le vol avec gens me le vole sur la scène
nissan ne puisse les incartades m
vous avez soif moi j'ai un peu soit
personnellement
alors vous allez bientôt atterrir faut
se dépêcher
on peut se dire aurevoir talent et
d'amour ont une fin donc comment ça
s'est passé
hélas
[Rires]
merci alors à votre avis jean-mi parce
que il ya vraiment joulié j'ai les
téléspectateurs c'est une vraie histoire
jean mis à vraiment une relation à bord
d'un vol dakar direction paris dans le
respect de pré-saison classe économie et
c'est ce que si oui c'était classe
économique est-ce que c'est awa la
première jeune fille est-ce que c'est
cathy ou est-ce que c'est mariama
honnêtement je pencherais pour maria
mariama mariama est ce que c'est vous
est ce que c'est vous mariama oui c'est
ce que c'est vous qui avez eu une
aventure il jean-michel mais on s'est
battu cathy alesi sur kaka timothy
d'agneau cas si tu ne sais plus ce
travail c'est vrai je suis envolé avec
toi mais tu as fait quoi qu'à passer les
parages où le narcissique qui tu es dans
ton journal comme ça j'en les autres
n'existaient même pas tu regardé comme
ça je travaillais inné bardon est ce que
tu as le moment d'avoir une relation
sexuelle avec montceau
[Musique]
mariama donc ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
gâté ce n'est pas maria bas et si
j'allais dire je vous jure que ça wahaha
venez nous rejoindre
oui c'est une vraie histoire
ça s'est passé sur un vol c'était un
dakar paris jean michel était là et vous
avez eu chacun l'un pour l'autre le coup
de foudre
surtout moi je crois c'est vrai au nom
si j'ai bonne mémoire
on était au sein des milieux je crois et
non tu faisais pas du tout attention à
moi s'il vous plaît est-ce que derrière
on peut ou peut se taire si vous payez
les cherry et ou baisser les micros
parce qu'il ya plein de téléspectateurs
qui disent qu'on entendait des sons
derrière donc merci si on peut alexandre
si tu peux t'en occuper vraiment que les
personnes ne parle plus derrière ce truc
là c'est un beau moment d'émotion et
j'espère que ce soit vous allez
reprendre parce que c'est vrai est ce
que j'ai de bonnes nouvelles
awa me l'a dit elle est célibataire ou
pas oui oui
aie aie aie très ému de revoir dans
michel oui vous m'avez dit un truc ma
vie dit il est encore plus beau en vrai
waouh c'est non on s'était vus on ferait
un nom mais s'est bonifié avec le temps
oui là c'est pas fou il est plus beau
quand vous l'avez rencontré c'était papa
est un petit peu débraillé
bon ça n'a pas changé non non je me
souviens je suis pas pourquoi il ya des
détails comme ça qu'ils qui marque je me
souviens de la chine c'était bordeaux je
crois c'est possible j'en ai eu
oui c'était la mode en plus d'un an il
avait juste renversé du vin sur sa
chemise hawaïenne bourrier jeu ce que
vous pourriez au revoir jean michel
c'est à dire bah le revoir peut-être
vous donner une seconde chance tous les
deux bien confinement malheureusement
tout dépend de 200 comportement parce
que
malheureusement je garde le mauvais pli
il est pas sérieux
je suis stressé en avion ce nom mais il
est pas sérieux
vous en êtes où vous senti mentalement
jusqu'à ce soir salle est pas mal ouais
demain je sais pas alors j'ai une copine
quand même en ce moment mais à terme on
pouvait prendre un verre en amitié
évidemment on ne respecte pas les
conflits si je fais une briseuse de
couple est ouvert non car je sais pas
fait pour ça non mais on évoque le bon
vieux temps au nom voilà vous êtes
contente de le revoir oui ça se voit il
est ému après c'est vrai à voir vous
êtes magnifique
ouais franchement jean-michel à moi
aussi oui mais moi kawa ah oui c'est moi
j'ai bu trois verres de jeu allez je
préfère awa garoua j'étais juste un tout
petit peu quand même vexé qui vous sera
fait pas de mal à baho sinon quatre noms
qui ne me reconnaisse pas bah oui disait
du rugby le masque pour dormir vous
savez classe en classe éco ya pas à oye
en tout cas pas pour nous ça a été un
vrai bonheur vous vous retrouvez jean
michel est ce que vous avez quelque
chose à dire ah oui parce que ça reste
un souvenir incroyable que je veux bien
les boire un verre en tout cas après on
faire pardonner s'il trouve que j'ai pas
été à la hauteur de ses espérances et
bien aller prendre un verre ensemble
cloud vous êtes magnifique merci d'avoir
été avec merci de vous embrasser un
effort et je vous sens très des musiques
fait plaisir merci à vous